yeah mom I'm really digging it yeah
no it's fun it's nice out now I haven't
not even joined the gang I don't think
I'll do that Rick's good yeah he's yeah
he's sober ish yeah my name is holding
up oh okay
I'll talk to you later mom bye love you
oh comedy open mic tomorrow night come
check it out or try it out first-timers
get on for sure well I won't be trying
it out I'm a dramatic actor I just moved
to town I'm very very serious stuff okay
so Robin Williams Jim Carrey and Jamie
Foxx never did both wake up man
expand your range bro yeah good point
come back and expand that range bro
karaoke bright lights big city
I thought you were gonna be a dramatic
actor
it's called range bro look at Jim Carrey
Robin Williams Academy Award winner
Jamie Foxx they all had a dude I could
do that you know it's I was class clown
though you weren't I was class clown
Rick you weren't in class or a parking
lot clown of course I'm gonna be there
bro you're gonna kill it I got you
thanks man does open mic me an open bar
huh so I was riding in a cab the other
day now super high right yeah and the
cab driver asked me um were you going
and I start talking like Matthew
McConaughey and and so I respond all
right all right all right
that dudes hilarious good luck following
that how many beers have you had
six but I did a bump of coke in the
bathroom so I'm good great look maybe
maybe this is a bad idea
what dude we came all the way down here
together you got this I know it's just I
overheard those those guys in the suits
are big agents Mike everybody know you
looks kind of Chinese tho that's a dude
I did coke with in the bathroom you guys
ready for next comic all right this
guy's new to town he wants to be an
actor give it up for Gary scaled-up you
got this buddy I the tiger I'll be in
the crowd supporting you okay I gotta go
better hey everybody
how are ya how's a warm welcome ah it's
good started yeah my name is Gary I am
new to Los Angeles and yeah traffic is
not great we all know that I'm not used
to it yet
yeah I was driving the air for the other
day and I watch great material let me
guess
airplane food is so bad Rick yeah um hey
nice haircut what time's the barbeque in
Ohio you dork hey nice gut what
dunkin donuts you work out at ah yeah
why don't you get hazed I have eight are
you all right now you will never get an
agent this town I didn't I
didn't know it right that was Gary
everybody
hi there he is dude you killed what in
the are you doing
why did you hack all me what do you mean
I came for support just like I said I
got your back dude we're a duo you know
like how we are in real life you didn't
let me get out a joke not one joke they
booed me and then the agents
walked out angry great yeah you made fun
of their age hey I don't even
know if they have AIDS I just blurted it
out it's a horrible thing to say about
anybody if they do or they don't have
AIDS so just calm down relax bro
it's gonna be okay listen you're a
dramatic actor comedy isn't easy dude
just not your thing I wouldn't know that
because I couldn't get out one joke so I
don't know that sorry bro my bad
let's just go get a drink and forget
about how terrible that was okay we said
it was fun I know hey sorry to interrupt
that was so great you were so funny in
there thanks man I mean no no no not you
your friend what's your name man Rick
you're hysterical you're my new favorite
comedian huh thank you whoa